The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GUEST SPEAKER: So
I'm going to try
to run through things
pretty quickly,
and if you don't have any sort
of video experience or still
photography experience, a lot of
this will sound foreign to you.
If you do, some of it
will be very familiar.
But either way,
if what I'm saying
is confusing because
of the density of it,
I would just sort of encourage
you not to be too freaked out.
Because the takeaways are
actually fairly simple.
It's kind of like--
again, there's
a lot of complicated
technology and a lot
of complicated technique, but
the base is pretty simple.
And what I'm going to do--
partly what I want to do today
is just expose you to
some concepts and terms
that you actually may not have
to really fully grasp or have
mastery of in order
to make your video.
But it's worth it to
at least kind of know
what they are I think.
PROFESSOR: And I can
condense my [INAUDIBLE].
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
But I do want to-- I'm
very cognizant of not
wanting to spend more
than like 30 minutes.
So can you tell me-- if
I'm like maybe 10 to 2:00,
just kind of give me
a wave or something.
And I'll condense even more.
OK.
So visual language, there's
sort of a question here--
what do we mean by
visual language?
Because it's kind of a
contradiction in terms.
Sometimes we think of
language and the visual
as being at odds
with each other.
We have text.
We have speech.
And we talk about, oh, well,
we've got to make a visual.
So what is a visual language?
It goes back to something
that I talked about
in the first class.
And in some ways what
I'm going to do today
is try to build on
some of those things
as I sort of race through them.
We have all of these
plastic elements of film
that we can manipulate.
And today I'm going to
focus on a handful of them,
in particular camera.
Because the camera is
kind of the speech device
that allows us to speak
in this visual language.
And Elizabeth made a
really interesting point,
or quoted a very
interesting kind of way
of thinking about it,
which was all of us
understand this language better
than any generation that's
ever lived, Because we just have
consumed it our entire lives.
But that doesn't
mean we can speak it,
and understanding that
is a great first step
in speaking it.
But you really have to kind of
unpack it and think about it
consciously in order to be
able to kind of reproduce
it or change it and make
it what you want it to be.
Anyway, so I'm going to
race through some of these
fairly quickly, focused
mostly on camera,
and I'm going to dispense
with sound right away.
Because I just want
to say about sound--
don't dispense
with it right away.
Don't do what I'm doing.
It is super, super important.
I think I mentioned
this the other day,
getting good sound is
absolutely critical.
And sometimes sound can be
more important than pitch
and all this stuff I'm
going to talk about.
It's also sort of the
boring part sometimes.
Well, you know, is the
microphone close enough to me?
I don't know.
Who's listening to me?
Am I OK?
Good.
All right, because
it's really important.
Because if you don't
hear me-- or even
if you can sort of hear
me, but it's a camera mic
and it's six feet away,
there's a huge barrier
between your audience
and your material.
So do not skimp on sound.
The environmental
sound is important.
It's important to
be in a quiet room.
It's important to have
good mic placement.
It's important not to have a
signal be too soft or too loud.
Listen with your ears.
And then creatively you can
do so much with sound too
with music and sound effects.
But I don't really have time
to talk about that stuff.
PROFESSOR: I'll go
over that stuff.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
Yeah.
OK, good.
I just want to sort of make
the pitch to not forget
about sound in all of this.
But let's go on and
talk about camera.
And I don't know if there
are any theater people here,
or people who have
done theater, but I
want to start with this
concept of the proscenium.
Film and video, film at
least, has been around
for over 100 years-- 125
years or something like that.
The sort of first
Edison experiments
or the Lumiere
brothers in France I
think it was the
late 19th century.
And for the first 20
years of the technology,
the way people kind of
accessed it or thought
about it and the kinds
of things that people did
were based on theater.
Because that, of course,
is thousands of years old.
In a theater, you
sit in an audience,
and there's a frame,
which is the proscenium.
And then stuff
happens in the frame.
And a lot of the
plastic elements
that we ran through the other
day are very, very relevant.
You've got lighting.
You've got staging.
You've got a frame, a sort
of placement of people.
You've got costumes.
You've got sound effects,
music even, all sorts
of things-- very, very similar.
But it all happens in
this kind of static frame
right there in the middle
of your field of view.
And it was really
literally about 20 years
before people started
going, oh, with a camera
we can do something a little
bit different than that.
The first films-- and these
were wildly popular films.
It was already a big industry.
Very quickly it turned into
a major, major entertainment
and communication industry.
But people would
set up a camera,
and then people would do their
thing in front of the camera.
And then they would
project the thing,
and people would be like,
wow, this is really cool.
This is like theater, except we
can watch it again and again.
And this is very relevant
to educational video,
because that is essentially
what a lecture is.
A lecture is a proscenium
presentation of material.
And the question which you're
asking yourselves in this class
is-- OK, we've got that.
We get that.
When we watch
media, whether it's
online or on television
or in a theater,
obviously we have
progressed way beyond that
visually, in terms
of visual language,
and the tools and techniques
that we use to do that
are the things that
you need to do in order
to become conversant
in this quote
unquote "visual language,"
not just a consumer of it
but a speaker of it.
So I'm going to
go over something
that is sort of like
a convenient bucket
to put things into, and
it's also easy to remember.
When I think about camera,
I think about the four F's.
And some of them
are F because I make
them be F. It just is easier.
So F-stop or
exposure-- and if you
know anything about
photography or film,
F-stop is the aperture
of the camera lens,
and you can let more
or less light in.
But what I mean by that
actually is not just
the F-stop or the
exposure of the lens,
but how you control the light.
It could be lighting.
It could be the shutter speed.
There are a million
different ways
of controlling the exposure
of what you're filming.
The second thing is focus.
The first thing about focus is
it's a good idea to have it.
It's kind of one of those
non-negotiable things.
You really do want something
to be in focus in your frame.
Sometimes you might not, but
it's better to do that in post.
Always make sure
something's in focus.
You may be working
with cameras that
take care of this for you--
both of these-- the exposure
and the focus.
I'm not sure.
Is that true?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So they're all working with the
[INAUDIBLE] or your iPhones.
The equipment that you
guys will be working
with, you won't have
to necessarily-- it's
not an element that you
can control necessarily
on the device itself.
GUEST SPEAKER: Or
you can control it
only by fooling
the device, which
is something you might
want to do if you get more
sort of comfortable with it.
PROFESSOR: To do focus
on these cameras,
you just literally touch the
touchscreen with your finger
where you want that
to be in focus.
And exposure,
we're going to have
to tweak with the external
lighting and stuff.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
Yeah.
99 times out of 100 it's
pretty straightforward.
And the auto systems
on newer cameras
are really pretty good about it.
So I'm not going to spend a
lot of time dwelling on that.
But they're kind
of non-negotiable.
You want to get a
good exposure, and you
want to get something in focus.
And 9 times out of
10 that something
is someone's face, the
person who you're filming--
not always but usually.
The third one is focal length.
And that is basically
how many millimeters
you are shooting at from
wide angle to telephoto.
And you're not going to be
changing lenses on the camera,
but you can zoom in and out.
Focal length is not the same
thing as wide shot or close up.
People often think that
that's true, but it's not.
You can go completely wide angle
on a camera, and then walk up--
I can walk right up to
Elizabeth and get a close up.
And similarly, I can go
all the way telephoto
and walk back 50 feet
and get a wide shot.
But they have very, very
different kinds of resonances
and feelings and emotions.
So I'll try to talk a little
bit about that in a minute.
You might want to do
everything at a very long lens.
everything at a wide angle.
It will mean
something different.
It will feel different.
Framing-- this is
the big one, and this
is kind of like the
catch all that I
throw all of this sort of real
thinking about visual language
into.
It's not just
framing as I talked
about the other day, like,
oh, gee, do I center somebody?
Do I put them on the
right or on the left?
It's the entire
structure of your video.
How am I going to shoot this?
Where I'm going
to put the camera?
How is it going
to edit together?
Is the camera going to move?
Is it not going to move?
So framing is the
big one, and that's
mostly what I'm going to talk
about today in that broader
context.
Quickly, so exposure-- just
to get this out of the way--
this is what an aperture
looks like and the lens.
Again, it's automated for you.
A big number means not a lot
of light getting through,
a little number means a lot
of light is getting through.
This affects the
exposure in a way
that I'm not going to get into.
But basically you have a
lot more depth of field,
a lot more will be in
focus the smaller the hole.
Because the photons that get
through are more directed,
they're less scattered.
And we talked about this.
Just as a sort of an example
of classic elements of film--
so these are two stills from
Science Out Loud videos.
I think we saw a little
bit of the Exoplanets video
the other day.
I don't know if you've
seen this one on plants.
PROFESSOR: I think they
did just a little bit.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
What I thought was really
interesting about these two
frames is if I was storyboarding
this, what would I draw?
I would draw something
like this-- medium shot,
presenting to camera.
But that doesn't
capture anything
about what is compelling
about these shots.
It's all the other stuff.
Here we are launching
into space, deep space,
to look at planets.
And here we are-- bright,
welcoming the world of plants.
It's kind of an obvious point.
But this tells us
nothing about that,
unless you then add a
lot of other information.
And that's kind of what
storyboarding is about.
It's not just about what
does my shot look like,
but it's about-- what is all the
stuff in the shot that's going
to really make it compelling?
And it's really a
great moment to start
thinking about locations--
a field of flowers.
Wow.
I guess I need a
field of flowers.
Where am I going to get that?
Or what if everything was black?
What if it's a black screen?
And how are we
going to shoot that?
Lighting-- I don't know if
that's even an option here.
I'm not going to go into it.
PROFESSOR: We have a
light kit if people are
interested in doing lighting.
But come talk to either one
of us during office hours
or after class or something.
GUEST SPEAKER:
The only thing I'm
going to say about lighting
is it's kind of like being
a doctor, like,
first do no harm.
If you bring the
lights out, and you
don't know what
you're doing, and you
aren't trained on the kit,
you can break the kit.
You can hurt yourself
or someone else,
or you can ruin your video.
On the other hand,
it's really, really
an important tool and
something that-- you
can't shoot certain
kinds of things
without some kind of lighting.
I'm not necessarily
recommending that you
try to use artificial lights
or become a lighting expert.
It's a little beyond the scope.
But if there's something like--
to go back to this example--
you have to light to
get a look like that.
Some kind of lighting
has to be done-- maybe
not film lighting
or video lighting,
but some kind of lighting set
up has to be created in order
to get a look like that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GUEST SPEAKER: I'm sorry.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE].
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh,
you can improve it,
but you have to begin
with something that's been
filmed with that intention.
PROFESSOR: If you have
an effect that you
want to do in your video, you
can come talk to me about it.
Because we achieve some of
these things with jankier props.
I've done-- I'm not proud to
admit this in front of Chris.
GUEST SPEAKER: No, that's OK.
PROFESSOR: I've done a shoot--
GUEST SPEAKER:
Oh, you don't even
know janky till you've been on
some of the shoots I've done.
PROFESSOR: I've done
a few with desk lamps
that I've covered with
white tissue paper
to help diffuse the light.
You don't need a
super fancy light kit
to achieve some of the basics.
GUEST SPEAKER: No, absolutely.
And that's exactly what
I'm about to get into.
To do sort of like
a darkroom thing,
you don't need a
fancy video light kit,
but you do need to
light the person.
And yeah, it could be a
desk lamp with paper over it
to sort of smooth it out,
to diffuse the light,
but you will need
to do something.
It's not going to
just magically happen.
And that's the point
of this-- lighting
doesn't necessarily
mean a video light kit.
It means being aware
of the environment
and the available light that
you're shooting in and taking
that into account either
by manipulating that thing,
like a light kit, or
by taking advantage
of the best light in the
world, which is the sun.
So for example, if I was
shooting in this room,
and I didn't have any lights--
I might love the background out
there.
But shooting somebody
in front of that window
is not going to be possible if
I want to get the background.
Because by the time I expose
for the person's face,
the background is going
to completely blown out.
And if I expose
for the background,
the person is silhouetted.
So unless I want
that look, I really
can't have it unless
I bring in lights.
And it would actually take
quite a bit of lighting.
Fluorescents-- you can do a
lot with fluorescent overheads.
The difference between me
standing here-- look at my face
here, and look at my face here.
Where do you want
your person to stand?
And you can manipulate
that kind of thing
even in a lab or a classroom
or some other setting.
You can make choices based
on the available light
or the ambient light
that will help you.
And the other thing to think
about in terms of exposure--
going back to
exposure-- is what do
I want to be properly exposed?
In that face floating
in blackness,
the face is properly exposed.
Everything else is
very, very dark.
But the face is
properly exposed.
In the flower shot, the whole
thing is properly exposed.
It's more even lighting.
There's some nice
modeling on the face.
But the whole point
of that is that you
want to see the environment,
you want to see the flowers,
you want to have this very
vibrant, bright scene.
So being very sensitive to
the light that's available
is part of lighting.
It's not necessarily setting
up a bunch of light stands
and video lights and spending
two hours when you should
have been shooting your scene.
Because it can also be
very time consuming.
PROFESSOR: Just a quick tip on
lighting-- since most of you
will probably be filming
indoors and relying
a lot on fluorescent overhead
lights, the only caveat
to that is that
oftentimes-- there are only
two people in here-- but for
me, the glasses is a big issue.
You'll get like a weird shadow
underneath on people's faces.
GUEST SPEAKER: Or a
glare in the lens.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, or a glare.
So you can compensate for that
with maybe a desk lamp that's
also shone on your face
from a little bit below
to hide some of those shadows.
GUEST SPEAKER: Particularly,
as Elizabeth mentioned,
if you diffuse that light
with some kind of tissue
or something in front
of it-- because one
thing about lighting-- the
first do no harm-- when you're
lighting faces,
harsh, direct light,
whether it's sunlight or
desk lamps or video lights,
are very unflattering.
So that's absolutely
a great tip.
But I think it's
always a good idea
to sort of try to diffuse it.
If it's not a hot
light, you can put
like a tissue or a white
paper towel in front of it,
and it will give this
very nice soft light.
PROFESSOR: But if you're
shooting something indoors,
and you just feel
like the person looks
a little funky on
the screen, it's
probably because it's
an overhead light that's
casting shadow.
So just experiment with
a desk lamp or something.
GUEST SPEAKER: And I'm not
going to go into focus too much.
Because again, I
know you're going
to be working with autofocus.
But just to say-- make sure that
what you want to be in focus
is in focus.
There are all
sorts of things you
can do to mess with
the depth of field,
which is like how much of
the plane of your image
is in focus.
So if you have a very--
if you're very wide open,
if there's not a
lot of light, then
suddenly you have
very shallow focus.
Which means that if
you were filming me,
my face might be in
focus, and the background
would be out of focus.
If you are stopping
way, way down
because there's a ton
of light, suddenly
it's a very deep focus situation
where everything's in focus.
And that may or may
not be a good thing.
You may not want more focus.
There's something very
nice about just what you
want to be in focus and
everything else being out
of focus, because that
makes people's eyes go
to what you want them to see.
It also creates
depth in the frame.
PROFESSOR: Does
everyone understand
what depth of field
in the frame means?
GUEST SPEAKER: Here I am.
I don't know if you've
seen this Science
Out Loud video, Engineering
Trash into Treasure.
I won't show it.
But it's got a
really nice opening,
which uses depth of
field really effectively.
So this is a person talking
about the creation of charcoal.
And in the foreground are the
props, and she's out of focus.
And it's kind of
counter-intuitive,
because your presenter
is out of focus
and the props are in
focus in the foreground.
But it's actually quite
engaging and interesting.
And then what they do--
and this is something
that you will have a hard
time doing if you are just
doing autofocus-- is they
shift the focus to reveal her.
And that's a reveal.
That's something we talked
about the other day.
Revealing things is part
of the visual language
that you want to think
about-- whether it's
a cut, with an edit, a change
of the angle, a pan, a camera
move.
Revealing your next
thing is really just kind
of a key visual element.
So here it's like the burning--
I forget what kind of--
PROFESSOR: Corn husks.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
The burning corn
husks come into frame,
and then the charcoal
comes into frame,
and then the focus shifts
and you reveal the person
who's been talking to you.
It's cool.
It's quite a nice
little opening.
PROFESSOR: It's really hard
to achieve depth of field
with these camcorders.
One way you can
sort of trick it is
if you stand really far in
front of your background.
That's the closest way you're
going to get that blurry
background effect.
So if you wanted to film in
this classroom for instance,
and you didn't want the
stuff on the chalkboard
to be really visible,
you would have
Chris move up all the way up to
maybe where David is at least
and then shoot from the
very back of the room.
GUEST SPEAKER: Right.
And so that's what this is.
So again, you have a zoom lens.
If you go all the
way wide on the lens,
you have much deeper focus than
if you zoom all the way in.
So if I walk up
and shoot Elizabeth
with a very wide angle,
everything behind her
will be in focus.
If I go way back there, and I
get the same kind of close up
of Elizabeth with a
longer part of the zoom,
everything behind her
will be out of focus.
Which might be
better if we don't
care about the background,
or if it's messy.
I've often been in labs
that just look horrible.
And the best way
to handle that is
to zoom way in, go way back,
and have the background be
way out of focus.
Or you can, as
Elizabeth mentioned,
you can bring the
person forward so
that there's a lot of
distance between the person
and the background.
So focus, focal length,
all of these things
relate to each other.
And again, we're going
to move a little quickly.
PROFESSOR: It's about 10 till.
GUEST SPEAKER: No, I'm
doing fine, I think.
I think I'm doing OK.
This is an extreme wide angle.
You can see how
deep the focus is.
It's infinity.
And this is a telephoto,
so it's a close up,
but even the leaf behind
the bird is out of focus.
Just a word about zooms-- so
there are two kinds of zoom,
and there's one kind
of danger-- well,
two kinds of danger actually.
Optical zoom, which is if you
zoom in and out with the zoom
control on your camera.
That is the way you
change the focal length.
Then there's digital zoom, which
is usually on these cameras--
I'm assuming these
are like this.
If you go past a
certain point, you're
not changing the
lens anymore, you're
just zooming in on the
image itself digitally.
The problem with that
is that your resolution
goes down immediately.
It looks really bad.
It starts to pixelate
and just fall apart.
So I would recommend that
you not use the digital zoom.
It's kind one of those
situations where people say,
oh, well, when I can use it?
I'm like, well, when the UFO
is landing in Killian Court,
and you're just too far
away to get the shot,
definitely use the digital zoom.
But if you have
time to do something
different or plan a
little differently
then stick with the optical.
PROFESSOR: And also realize
that you can zoom in on a frame
and post when you're editing.
So it's generally better to
just capture something wider.
So say you want to do like a
traditional interview set up,
and you're not
sure how close you
should be into your subject.
Go ahead and err on
the side of zooming out
as much as possible.
You can always play
with how much you
zoom when you're editing later.
And the other thing about
zooming-- maybe this
is just a matter of
personal preference.
But generally, I don't like it
when I see the camera zooming
in live time.
I prefer seeing just a
clean cut from a wider
angle to the zooming angle.
GUEST SPEAKER: And
that's the other part
of the danger for sure.
Yeah.
Zooms in general--
unless you're doing it
because you know what you're
doing-- all these rules
are made to be broken.
That's something I should
mention right up front.
They're often kind of
the lazy person's way
of doing something.
And in general, I
would even go so far as
to say even if
you're not planning
to show the zoom-- if I was,
again, filming Elizabeth,
and I wanted to get a wide
shot, so I shoot her here.
And then I want a close up.
And I zoom in on Elizabeth,
and I get the close up.
There's something
kind of unpleasing
about going from a wide angle
shot to a zoomed in telephoto
shot of somebody.
The more sort of
smart way to do it
is to pick a focal
length that makes
Elizabeth look great and
gives you what you want
and then move the camera in.
Don't change the focal
length of the lens
when you change the
size of the shot.
So maybe I end up
on a medium shot,
in terms of the focal length.
And then when I want to get the
close up, I pick up the camera,
and I walk in and
get the close up.
And that's going to cut better,
it's going to look better,
it's going to feel better.
It's going to feel like
just more controlled
and like you sort of
knew what you were doing.
So zooms-- very useful,
dangerous as well.
All right, so back
to the proscenium.
I just want to say a
little bit about framing.
What shots do you actually
need to tell your story?
Well, the way you figure
that out is exactly
the way you do it with
animation or anything else,
you do a storyboard.
And this is a storyboard I did
a few years ago for a narrative
scene.
But you'll see it contains
a lot of the things
that we've talked
about in this class.
Who's our main character?
This kid.
How do we know that?
Well, the next shot
is a point of view
of what this person is seeing.
There's a moving shot up, and
the next thing that you see
is his grandfather's reveal.
You see what they're looking at.
And only then do
you actually see
a wide shot, which is a
home-built airplane being
pushed down a field.
So this is kind of
visual storytelling--
a very simple thing.
Who's our character?
What do they see?
Who's around them?
And then revealing
the whole scene--
it could have been done
completely differently.
This could have
been the first shot.
It could have been--
let's establish the scene.
Let's see all the people.
Then let's kind of cut in
and see our main character,
or maybe it's revealed later.
There's no right or
wrong answer here.
But the point is is
that what you want to do
is think through your scene
just as you do with animation.
That whole process that
Josh took you through
is completely relevant
to absolutely everything
that you're going to shoot.
Just a few notes about
what different shots do.
Wide shots establish the
location, the environment,
the spatial relationships.
They add production value.
I don't know about
you, but if I could
go to the top of this bridge,
I would shoot this shot.
I wouldn't not, because
this is awesome.
And that's happened.
I've seen that happen.
People get an incredible
location, an incredible view,
and they don't get a shot
that shows where they were.
That's what we call
production value.
Similarly, I think this
is an awesome picture.
This was actually taken in 1911.
This is a pre-revolution
Russian nobleman
in a tiny village in Russia.
It was taken in 1911.
It's an amazing picture.
But I would feel like
I missed a huge amount
if it was just his face.
You learn so much
about the environment,
you learn so much about the
person, by having a wide shot.
If this was a video, I might
want to also have a close
up when I started to hear about
him and learn about who he was.
But boy, this is great.
How could you miss that?
So again, showing environments,
getting production value,
establishing characters and
relationships, relationships
and space.
Closer shots-- well,
they kind of bring you
into someone's world.
They reveal details--
closer shots
of a face, closer shots of
what the person is looking at.
If you're explaining
something, obviously,
really good close shots
that show the angle,
show from a good angle what
you're trying to describe
are very, very important.
So again, it's kind
of obvious, but just
make sure to get those as well.
You want to get the wide shot.
But if you're actually
describing a process that's
like a physical process
that somebody is doing,
make sure you document it well,
and that you don't shoot it
from the angle where
the person's hand is
covering the key thing.
Just look at your frame
and see if you're actually
communicating what you
want to communicate.
Moving shots-- endless
kinds of moving shots.
You can pan the
camera on a tripod.
You can walk with a camera.
You can move on a dolly.
They have all sorts
of good great uses.
They reveal story beats.
If, again, to keep
picking on Elizabeth,
if I want to introduce
Elizabeth, and I dolly
or pan over to
Elizabeth, people want
to know what the end of
that shot is going to be.
What am I going to see?
Oh, this person,
who's a character
that I am supposed
to pay attention to.
Or you can follow a person,
it creates a very strong point
of view.
If someone's walking and talking
and you're following them,
then we pay attention
to that person,
because the camera is picking
them out of the background
to pay attention to.
So that's part of
this visual language.
Similarly, we could
do a point of view
of that person's
walking, and then we're
suddenly into their world.
So kind of a classic situation
is someone's walking,
we're following them, and
then you cut to the reverse,
and you see what they see.
And now we're in their head.
So it's another great thing.
And then there's just kind
of the classic one of we
have reptile brains-- this
is the same reason we edit it
quickly.
Here's a new thing, you can
either cut to a new thing,
or you can pan or
dolly to a new thing.
Let's see-- just a quick
word about locations.
You're going to talk
about this too, but always
scout your locations.
It's smart producing,
which Elizabeth
is going to talk about, but
it's also very smart creatively.
I have been in so
many situations
where I've gone to a location
a few days in advance,
and I have completely
rewritten my script
based on the location.
Either because I saw a problem
that I wasn't anticipating--
like a classic one
is, OK, well, we're
going to film all this stuff
at the electron microscope,
but there's a column here,
and I can't shoot anything
from this angle.
Oh, shit.
It's really good to find that
out a few days in advance,
because you can't
move the microscope.
So what are you going to do?
Or because the location
is really cool,
and there's amazing stuff.
And you get very
excited, because there's
all sorts of possibilities that
open up that you couldn't have
ever imagined just sitting,
doing your own story
board in your room or
writing your script.
But suddenly because
this place is amazing,
you see all sorts of
things that you could do.
So I always suggest trying
to visit your location.
One, for just kind of
practical scouting reasons,
like is there a chainsaw
factory next door?
But two, because
it can completely
affect your creative vision.
And try to do it
enough in advance
so that you can
incorporate what you learn.
So I'm going to just
wrap up with a couple
words about editing.
This is where all of
the stuff comes together
and where you find out
whether your plan worked--
your storyboard, your visual
language, your script.
And it's also where you fix all
the things that didn't work.
And I guarantee you that
plenty of things will not work.
Just a word about pacing,
B-roll, and transitions.
So pacing is kind of
like how much do I edit.
And this is kind of
the big question,
like, gee, what's the big thing?
What's the secret?
What's my pacing?
What should it be like?
And I don't think there
is an answer to this.
When I was in film
school 20-plus years ago,
I was being taught by people
who were trained in the 1950s.
And people who were
trained in the 1950s
would tell us, well, you
really can't edit faster
than four seconds per shot.
Because the human brain just
can't comprehend an image
that lasts shorter
than four seconds.
And I remember dutifully
editing my very first piece
and following that rule
and watching it and going,
this sucks.
This is terrible.
What's wrong with this?
This is awful.
And it's because four
seconds is a really long time
in some cases, in a lot
of cases, in many cases,
in most cases.
And that has increased--
has only increased.
My idea of a fast
edit may be completely
different than your idea of a
fast edit because I'm older.
I don't know.
And there's also the
difference between genres.
I think Elizabeth
mentioned this briefly,
television-- there's this sort
of like bombard everybody.
If you want to show
an establishing shot
of a house in a reality
TV show, you can't just
show one shot or two shots.
You have to show eight shots.
They're each 12 frames long,
like, boom, boom, boom, boom,
boom, with drums going.
Just to make the reptile
brain go, oh, yeah,
this is important somehow.
I don't know.
And it gets kind of
absurd at a certain point,
and it can be,
obviously, overediting.
But the more typical
experience that people
who are just
starting out have is
that they don't shoot enough,
not that they shoot too much.
You think, oh, I've
got three shots,
and this is going to cover
like 30 seconds of my video.
But 30 seconds can
be an eternity.
And if your shots
aren't telling a story,
that could be pretty skimpy.
Which brings us to
B-roll, I'm going
to talk about that in one
second with an example.
The other thing, though, to
think about is transitions.
How do I get from this to that?
Obviously, you can just cut.
But is there an issue--
like I'm cutting
from a medium shot of
Chris talking, talking,
talking, to a medium shot
of Elizabeth talking,
talking, talking.
That's not necessarily
super compelling.
Do I need some other
way of transitioning?
Do I need a wide shot
of the classroom?
Do I need people listening?
What other shots do I
need to tell my story
and to transition
from scene to scene?
The B-roll I just
wanted to mention.
Have you guys talked about
what that even means at all?
OK.
I was going to show
this in the PowerPoint.
But B-roll is a term that
goes back, way, way back,
like 80 years ago, when
people edited on film.
The B-roll was the
second roll of film
that they would then composite
over the first roll of film.
And it was all the stuff
that wasn't included
in the sort of main narrative.
And I'll show you what
I mean in a minute.
This is just a little
snippet from a video
that we shot not too long
ago with Jeff Hoffman, who's
a professor here in
AeroAstro, a former astronaut.
And we had done a storyboard
and kind of a script plan.
So we knew when he was going
to be on camera and when not.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The design, construction, and
operation of aerospace vehicles
have allowed us to leave
the surface of the earth
and fly through our planet's
atmosphere and out into space.
I'm Jeff Hoffman.
I'm a professor in the
Department of Aero--
[END PLAYBACK]
GUEST SPEAKER: So
anyway, we knew
that he wasn't going to be
on camera in the first part.
So we were able to
cut between takes.
We didn't even
bother to really have
him be compelling on
camera at that point.
But here we knew he
would be on camera,
so we filmed him that way.
And the first string
out is just literally
putting together your
script in a very linear way,
the way you wrote it, without
any kind of fancy stuff.
And then I'll just show you
what it looked like after.
I'll just show the first 10
seconds, and then I'll be done.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Commencing sequence
start-- 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1, 0.
All engines running.
Lift off.
We have a lift off.
32 minutes past the hour,
lift off on Apollo 11.
-Have you ever wondered
how rockets work?
Have you ever looked out of
the window of an airplane
and wondered how something so
big and heavy can actually fly?
Have you ever
wondered what happens
to the human body
in space, or how
a spacesuit keeps
astronauts alive and able
to work in the vacuum of space?
These topics are all part
of aerospace engineering.
Aerospace engineering is
giving humans the freedom
to move in three dimensions.
The design, construction, and
operation of aerospace vehicles
have allowed us to leave
the surface of the earth
and fly through our planet's
atmosphere and out into space.
-Mission specialist
Jeff Hoffman.
-Hello, Jeff?
-I'm Jeff Hoffman.
I'm a professor in the
Department of Aeronautics
and Astronautics at MIT.
Before coming to MIT,
I spent 19 years at--
[END PLAYBACK]
GUEST SPEAKER:
[AUDIO OUT] We were
able to shoot with him very,
very quickly, because we
knew what we needed on camera.
And we knew that
we were going to be
able to cover and fill
and sort of explain things
with other imagery.
In this case, a lot of it's
obviously archival stuff,
but it could be
stuff that we shot.
And later in the video
there is stuff that we shot,
but it was all the same plan.
Anyway, I know that's a
lot of stuff thrown at you,
but I'm also
cognizant of the time.
So we can talk about this after
class, too, if you would like.
Thanks.
PROFESSOR: So just to give
another example of B-roll
maybe on a more likely
level for you guys,
because I assume you won't be
going out into outer space.
GUEST SPEAKER: Well,
neither did we.
I called NASA.
NASA is a great resource.
PROFESSOR: For
Anastasia's video--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-What do these awesome
compounds have in common?
They all come from plants!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: You notice that she's
not talking over any of it.
We put the B-roll
in because we needed
to give the video a little
bit of space to breathe.
Otherwise it would have been
just her talking constantly
and saying facts.
So we wanted to help with the
pacing of the video, which is
what Chris was talking about.
So that's why we shot B-roll.
So if you're--
especially you, Paul,
because I imagine you're going
to shoot some stuff maybe with
a boat, sort of like you have
access to certain equipment.
Whoever you're filming
with, you're not only
going to shoot, Paul,
but I would also
spend some time maybe just
doing a pan of your environment,
shooting some of the
equipment that's around.
It may not be super
relevant to what you're
talking about exactly
in those moments,
but you can always
have that footage
to intersperse like we did
here, if that makes sense.
And as Chris was saying,
you're not always
going to shoot B-roll yourself.
NASA, I guess, is
what you guys used.
And all of their
stuff is-- they're not
copyrighted or licensed.
So you can use that footage.
There's a lot of-- there a
lot of photos and pictures
that you can look up.
I'm going to talk a little
bit more about music
that you can use, and I can
hit graphics as well next week
during the editing lecture.
But there are
resources out there,
if you want certain footage that
you just can't shoot yourself.